last year 32 transgender identifying
people were murdered and of course every
death is a tragedy but 32 deaths does
not a genocide make especially when
those deaths are often associated with
other risky behaviors and circumstances
things like prostitution in addition to
unusual gender identity
by comparison more than 20 percent of
all transgender identifying young people
in the United States attempted suicide
last year that's according to another
pro-lgbt group The Human Rights Campaign
which means that even according to the
transgender movement's own statistics
the biggest threat to trans identifying
people in the United States is not the
so-called transphobes the biggest threat
to trans identifying people in the
United States is themselves and it is
this Preposterous and wicked ideology
that is wreaking so much Havoc
personally and politically for
individual people who are personally
feeling it but for our whole society as
well